okay so this is my spoiler review of the
new Amazon Prime series the boys now if
you haven't seen it go watch my spoiler
free review because there is gonna be
spoilers galore here the whole series so
please make sure to leave now if you
haven't seen the whole series
okay so jumping into it let me just say
I had low expectations for the show I
have not read the comic before but the
low expectations came from me seeing
that Seth Rogen was an executive
producer and the last time he touched a
comic book series by Garth Ennis which
would be preacher that show to me took a
huge dip and got pretty bad so I lost a
little faith in that combo but I was
totally shocked at how good this was and
you'll notice right away I mean come on
that premiere was insane of this and
just to have that moment where he loses
his girlfriend like that and you're
wondering wait what just happened it was
so timed perfectly that you did not see
it coming at all and the way they set up
was kind of just like art where's this
show going what's really going on here
was just chill and then that to happen
like this Big Bang and to have in that
same moment the reveal it's a superhero
so you're like oh this is where we're
going now it's already making everything
gray here and it's to me was just so
effectively like this updated version of
Watchmen and it was cool because I
didn't read the comics of the boys I'm
planning to but from people have read it
that have talked to me about this it's
cool that they're taking a lot from the
comics but they're also making a lot of
their own choices for the show that are
different and I think the smartest thing
they did is updating a lot of stuff and
to me the whole thing with deep dive and
Starlight was brilliant I think this
show is one of the first shows to show
really accurate you know representation
of like the me to situations that are in
the news and what happens and how it
happens and it hits you with that in the
premiere as well and I love that I love
star light she was great character she's
a it's really just good casting as well
she's very likable easy to root for and
I like that you have one of these seven
connected
you a group of the boys now I think that
the highlight for me is the main
villains here with obviously homeland er
here oh my god Anthony Starr I didn't
know who this guy was but I am blown
away how good he did this I mean he
didn't miss a note and he was chilling
and he's kind of made this his own this
role and that it's separating from other
TV villains we've seen it's its own
thing and it's really really awesome and
I love that the character of homeland ER
is like a mix of Superman and Captain
America and it's uh it's just he was
always a scene stealer and that includes
his crazy boss Madelyn who's played by
the great Elisabeth Shue and she was so
good here and to me
their relationship was so interesting I
love the whole mother-son weird thing
going on where he likes a mommy comfort
because he didn't really have a mom and
I just thought that works so well and
that odd chemistry they had was perfect
and yeah I mean I think that it's
bittersweet that those look as she was
character dies in the finale because it
is such an awesome twist but I'm gonna
miss her terribly on the show she was
always a treat to watch but it's also
awesome that at least if they're gonna
have big shoes to fill with her they got
Gus from Breaking Bad Giancarlo Esposito
awesome better call Saul who's always
amazing as a villain so that got me
excited and still gives me hope in that
department
I thought the acting by all of the
actors in the seven were great now where
the acting was a little questionable for
me it was actually with Huey I think
that he I've never seen Quaid and
anything before but I'm not sold on him
yet I think there were some parts that
just I didn't fully buy when he was
doing reactions of shock or terror that
he was really fully in the scene
especially with some of the extreme
stuff going on around him so I hoped
that his chops get up more in season two
especially because this is now shows
getting bigger and bigger and they're
already filming season two and I hope
he'll have more experience under his
belt but I did think there was some like
early jitters especially in the early
episodes of him and I think he got
better as it progressed but I'm not sold
in erm I see potential I don't think
he's bad but I'm not sold on all those
reactions yet now Billy the butcher was
excellent I think that Karl Urban just
is an underrated actor and he kills it
here and I'm happy he's gonna get a role
that really puts him in the spotlight
and his accent was something that threw
me off at first because everyone was
saying it was British in the show but
then he sounds to me like Australian but
then I was reading about it and it's
like purposely a little misleading and
confusing and it's again you gotta
remember this show is also making in
front of what it is in a way and all
those kind of topics so there's so much
humour and you got to kind of see it
it's very satirical here and I think
that's also what separates this show
from the rest is that it brilliantly
somehow does such a realistic take on
what I believe would happen in real life
today
if superheroes are around like this is
the most realistic thing you're gonna
say I mean just from how they're still
puppets of big corporations and that
they're just products here and
everything goes back to their followers
and how hot they are and I love how a
train is just getting you know kind of a
has-been getting older and deep-dive
just got exiled for his bad behavior and
he's just can't get over that he's not
like famous anymore so or have purpose
and that he's the fish guy no one cares
what the fish guy so I really thought
that was so well done and that homeland
er is just a messed up dude who people
look as this huge hero and I thought one
of the best scenes was with him and the
Wonder Woman asked superhero where
they're on the plane and he's like yeah
we got to get out of here like this
we're not be able to save these people
and she's like what and that just shows
his level of darkness compared to any of
the seven and that he just goes with two
other little girls like I don't worry
you're gonna be fine he's like let's get
out of here like that was insane to me
and I thought that was just so well done
and how he twists everything how he
twisted that to be like oh now we're
gonna get those terrorists what they've
done and angles
and I just thought it was so brilliant
that every move that him and Madeline
were doing was just like these brilliant
moves that just make villains more
interesting especially when they're
really smart like a home Lander and the
twist the choice at the end they thought
was great and that's where you see on
the message boards that's different than
the comics doesn't happen in the comics
that big twist and how they're setting
it up and that the butcher you know his
wife was alive which I did figure I was
a check for that part but I was shocked
that it's more angled now that she
wasn't raped by homeland er it's pretty
much insinuating that she just willingly
cheated and had this kid and I'm
guessing she was blackmailed by Madeline
to stay hush-hush and just go away about
it that's my theory on that but it's
gonna be saying now what the hell
happens with butcher this was his whole
motivation here and now he's seeing home
Lander probably didn't rape her and that
oh man Rebecca's got some things some
explaining to do so maybe his judgment
on the soups will change one of the
complaints I had with the writing here
was it felt a little fast on huge
transition to wine to keep a train alive
because a big motivation for him at the
start of the season was obviously to
kill the guy or not necessarily kill but
get revenge on the man who killed his
girlfriend so for him to want to just
quickly revive him after being just into
killing translucent was fast and I know
there was some progression there but we
felt rushed like it still was just whoa
let that breathe like it was back to
back and forth where he's mister not
kill anybody then he makes that jump and
kills translucent but then he's back to
a train the guy who probably wanna kill
the most and he's like not a now let's
revive him so I didn't like that I even
thought the whole a train starlight
sequence was a little sloppy it was
genius that she shot to the sides cuz he
knew he was quicker than light to get
him which was awesome but I just thought
the whole thing felt we were especially
him with the heart palpitations and
having too much of the juice they take
so but that was a little strange again I
don't know how to feel about some of the
deep-dive stuff but I like it it's crazy
it's wonky but I think it keeps that
comic feel to it and I like how this
real
does a show work towards most audiences
I think people don't like super stuff
we're gonna dig this I think people I
know who aren't usually into that like
it so far which is exciting I think it's
why it's gonna be a big hit and already
kind of is but yeah I just I feel like
the Huey things a little off with his
character where he goes sometimes but
we'll see I think it'll pan out well and
this is just this isn't even the show so
I'll just a character's fault but I hope
again I have read the comics but I hope
that the mute character of the Asian
girl starts talking soon because I'm
just I don't know for me story-wise I'm
sick of like that trope or it's like
just there's always a mute character and
someone's falling in love with them and
they're not talking and it's like come
on let's just get them smarter now let's
go cuz it's just can get boring quick
but yeah I'm sure that's gonna change
soon and I plan to read the comics which
I'm excited about
I love Frenchie the actor of Frenchie
was awesome he's probably the most
likable in the show and yeah and
Mother's Milk was great too he was
really good so you see a lot of these
newer face actors that are really really
embracing this and doing an awesome job
and I think a lot of people can relate
to all these characters as well which is
awesome I think again stories like this
where everyone's got a dark side to them
basically making them human everyone's
gray and even people we look up to like
superheroes so they're even gray or
they're pretty evil so and then once you
start thinking deeper it makes you think
about who's controlling the Subaru so I
love that there's an endless stream of
that and you just questioning who you
even believe in or accept as good or
understand or root for it's kind of
keeps you moving in that sense and that
I think obviously keeps you interested
but it's really exciting I think this is
really gonna just push Amazon Prime that
next level it's stepping it up as a
whole as a streaming service and again
the special effects were just incredible
here it looked like I was watching a
movie special effects so Amazon Prime's
now investing their money now more into
their production value for their shows
which is great they got a couple hits
now and the streaming wars have begun
here and Disney Plus is on the rise and
some Netflix guys step your game up a
bit here and I was on Prime's here to
play as well so we'll see what happens
with that I'm giving this season of the
boys and eight
eight I would say it's B+ territory
almost in a so close I really did enjoy
it I really dug it but again I can't
ignore the fact that something's felt
off especially with Kiwis character
choices and a little bit of lull in the
middle there was a little slow and
moments of disinterest not it's few and
far between but I still felt it's not
perfect I mean some people giving an
a-plus-plus but hold the brakes you know
it's I think the potential for in the
season two is to be a plus plus but this
was really good setup and a nice
surprise of the year so yeah let me know
you thought of it down below I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this but please no
spoilers from the comics that is not for
here we were just talking the TV show
please not and if you see one please
just let me know and please follow me at
Steve rd1 on Twitter and screen for more
of me and please subscribe so don't miss
one of my reviews of TV shows or movies
I do and I do a bunch and also I do
celebrity interviews of the actors
themselves so come on board and I'll be
reviewing mine hunter next so stay tuned
for that and I'll see you next time